One of the best lines in "Wakanda Forever"
wasn't even in the script. Here's the story
behind the improvised moment fans
can't get enough of. Spoilers ahead.
The sequel to one of Marvel's most
successful movies, "Black Panther:
Wakanda Forever" is already setting records of its
own, having broken records for a November opening.
Set in the wake of King T'Challa's death,
which mirrors the real-life death of his actor,
Chadwick Boseman, the movie explores
how that loss affects those who were
closest to the late monarch. That
means "Wakanda Forever" functions
a lot like an ensemble film, despite its
central character arc belonging to Shuri.
For instance, actor Winston Duke gets
a lot more screen time as M'Baku,
ruler of the mountain-dwelling Jabari
Tribe. M'Baku's role is much expanded in
"Wakanda Forever" compared to the first
"Black Panther," and he's become much
more connected to the rest of Wakanda, even
holding sessions with the kingdom's elders.
But while M'Baku may have softened a bit, he's
still the intimidating wall of muscle fans know
and love. Though his gruffness belies kindness
and humor underneath, it's still a lot of fun
to watch M'Baku towering over everyone around
him and throwing his weight around. Some of
the most memorable lines in the film belong to
him. You could even call him a scene stealer.
"I bet you could."
"But no."
In fact, Duke came up with a few of those
lines himself. The actor took to Twitter to
reveal at least one fan-favorite line that
wasn't in the script. In a post on Twitter,
Duke revealed that the moment when
M'Baku, using a carrot as a pointer,
calls Okoye a "bald-headed
demon" was, in fact, improvised.
As Duke explained, part of his role in
"Wakanda Forever" was to act as comic
relief in tense situations, and that aspect
of the role led him to come up with some of
M'Baku's dialogue. Duke wrote in his tweet,
It's true that M'Baku's role in the film goes a
long way to diffuse the heavy atmosphere hanging
over the proceedings. Few other characters
in "Wakanda Forever" are afforded many
opportunities to express their comedic sides,
so M'Baku's funniest lines help to balance out
the movie's darker tones. Even if the character
isn't aware he's being humorous, Duke sure is.
But Duke's tweet implies that other M'Baku
dialogue across the film was also his own
improvisational deviation from the
script, thus raising the question:
which other lines did Duke come up
with? That mystery is sure to prompt
at least some fans to pay extra attention
to M'Baku's dialogue on a second viewing.
Fans of "Wakanda Forever" were excited
to learn that Winston Duke improvised
his "bald-headed demon" line from the
film. In response to the actor's tweet
revealing that bit of behind-the-scenes
lore, his replies were filled with fans
who expressed how much they had loved his
performance and that line in particular.
One fan posted,
Others were even more hyperbolic, with another
fan receiving hundreds of likes for posting,
"Wakanda Forever" won't be the last
fans see of M'Baku. The end of the
film implies that he will take over as
the new king of Wakanda, at least for
the time being. Whenever the MCU returns to
Wakanda, M'Baku is almost sure to be there.